(light music)
- We as humans have always
used dogs to help us get
what we want and what we need.
We make amazing teams because
we've evolved together,
and they make a massive
difference in conservation
by finding things that
we couldn't possibly find
to give us information
to help save species.
Our dogs use their sense
of smell to find everything
from endangered species
to invasive species
and wildlife crime which is
something we're really proud of.
(light music)
Come on, guys.
Let's go for a walk.
I'm Megan Parker.
I'm research director and co-founder
of Working Dogs for Conservation.
(light music)
Easy.
Wait.
OK.
We're an organization that finds dogs
from rescue situations,
shelters or career change dogs.
We train them as detection
dogs for conservation projects
around the world.
Right now we're on the way from the kennel
to the armory to pickup
two new elephant tusks
and a leopard skin and
a pangolin to train on.
We're training the dogs on new samples.
That might be finding
scats of endangered species
and doing a population estimate;
finding live animals that are
endangered that are very rare;
helping fight wildlife crime in Africa
by having dogs find ivory
and rhino and bush meat
and guns and ammunition
that are used for poaching.
- They can detect
microscopic larvae in water.
They can detect one species
of fish in a moving stream
that needs to be removed
from the ecosystem
before it harms more animals or plants.
You could imagine, like, well,
we could build a computer
that would sense odors or
sense particles of some object
in the environment except we
can't build anything that fine.
Dogs are actually the best
technology and the best able
to detect something, and
then tell their handler
what they know.
(light music)
I started out as a kid
training dogs when I was 10,
and I just kept that interest.
I became a biologist, and I got my Ph.D.
studying African wild dogs.
This has been a theme, I
guess, for me in my life.
I do have dogs myself.
I actually live with three dogs.
Two of them are working
dogs, one is retiring.
He's on the couch, I'm guessing, oh,
they're both on the couch.
(laughing)
This morning we started
Tule on an endangered bat
that she'll be working on.
It's really simple at first.
When she smells the bat,
she sits and gets her toy.
Let's go to work.
Yes, good girl!
Go!
Get it, look.
And then we move to really
complicated scenarios
where the dogs learn to find the scent
of an endangered animal in
a very hard to find place.
Most of our dogs come from shelters
or from a situation
where somebody can't keep
a dog like this.
We look at anywhere from
one to two thousand dogs
before we find a dog
that makes our standards
and can make it to the field
as a working dog for conservation.
We're gonna run Utah on the kick fox scat.
Is there anything in
particular you want to work on?
- He's solid, yeah, he knows ...
- These dogs have really high
energy, they want to play
with a toy, and without a job,
their energy gets misdirected
into tearing up your
couch or killing the cat
or jumping through a
window or chasing whatever.
So these dogs are really
hard to have as pets,
but when they have a job
and have a great home,
it's an awesome combination.
- Hi, orb, oh my gosh, I know,
we haven't worked
together since canarosis.
- A lot of the dogs that
I've personally trained,
I thought it would be really hard at first
to have them live on another continent,
but the care and the bonds
that they have formed
with their scouts and how hard they work
and the kind of work that they do
when I see them there working,
it's an awesome life for them.
Our work is important, it
pairs these two things I care
a lot about which is taking
dogs that are on death row
and then they get to amplify
all this conservation
that we care about that we want to do.
The dogs are making the
world a better place;
they really are making wildlife safer
in places where they work.
(light music)